didn't they add masculinity to the DSM
recently So eventually tsm-5 was that
really yeah DSM-5 access to diagnosis
like or something like that they added
toxic masculinity I could be
misremembering that I thought somebody
said that they added masculinity to the
to the DSM so maybe at one point anyone
who wants to own a gun anyways would be
seen as somehow masculine or toxically
masculine crazy so the story was in 2019
they called traditional masculine
masculinity harmful and faced an upper
armor I don't know if it was added to
the DSM-5 or anything no they made the
dsm-6 wouldn't it yeah I don't um I'm
concerned you need the new version of
the update by the way that's the letters
on the access to diagnoses of the
different you know disorders that one
can have you know multiple
that's the language way that they get
you to remember it used to be toxic
masculinity now it's not that now it's
just traditional masculinity and
eventually it'll just be masculinity at
all yeah at all and it'll just be men